quel est le rapport entre joseph
pulitzer jules verne et american horror
story un indice c'est le titre de la
vidéo
le rapport c'est nelly blaye et on va
voir pourquoi tout de suite nelly blaya
aînée elizabeth cocheren en pennsylvanie
le 5 mai 1864 elle perd son père à l'âge
de 6 ans est d'abord destiné à devenir
gouvernante mais elle s'intéresse très
tôt à l'écriture à 16 ans elle est un
article du pittsburgh 10 matches
particulièrement misogyne et dont le
titre et ce pour quoi les filles sont
fait faire des enfants et le ménage en
gros l adresse une lettre bien sentie au
rédacteur en chef qui la rencontre et
lui lance un défi ils l'engagent si elle
lui propose un meilleur article
c'est très vite chose faite grâce à un
papier qu'elle les rangs sur le divorce
elle prend alors le pseudonyme de nesle
et blaye d'après de vieilles chansons
folk américaine notamment pour protéger
sa famille parce que les articles
qu'elle s'apprête à écrire pourrait lui
causer du tort elle montre très vite
qu'elle ne va pas se contenter de la
rubrique chiens écrasés pour l'un de ses
premiers articles elle se fait embaucher
dans une fabrique de boîtes de conserve
et y observe de l'intérieur les
conditions de travail des ouvrières elle
est l'initiatrice du journalisme
d'investigation et du reportage
clandestin qui reste sa marque de
fabrique par la suite afin de démêler le
vrai du faux dans ce que racontent les
ouvrières sur leurs salaires et leurs
conditions de travail déplorables
j'avais en effet décidé de me faire
embaucher dans un atelier je me mets
donc à la recherche d'un emploi ne
nécessitant pas la moindre expérience ni
références ou quoique ce soit d'autre
pouvant jouer en ma faveur
elle témoigne de l'insécurité et des
faibles salaires du harcèlement des
patrons son reportage fait exploser les
ventes du journal mais elle subit alors
des pressions de certains industriels
malgré le succès de son enquête nelly
est rabattue à l'aide de briques art et
théâtre pour se changer les idées elle
décide en 1886 de partir six mois au
mexique avec sa mère de là à l'envoi au
journal des articles sur les moeurs des
coutumes la vie culturelle cassant les
préjugés que les américains ont sur ce
pays mais elle écrit aussi sur le
gouvernement mexicain envers lequel elle
se montre très critique
elle devient menacé sur place et décide
de précipiter son retour en sachant
qu'elle risquait d'être bientôt expulsés
du pays
elle tire de cette expérience son
premier livre six mois au mexique dont
le succès lui permet de quitter
pittsburgh et d'aller tenter sa chance à
new york
encore une fois on lui propose un défi
joseph pulitzer du new york world lui
promet de langage et si elle parvient à
enquêter sur l'hôpital psychiatrique
blackwell alors le 22 septembre 1887 le
world me donnait pour mission de me
faire interner dans l'un des asiles de
foot de new york
mon rédacteur en chef joseph pulitzer
souhaité que je décrive en termes
simples et directs des soins apportés
aux patientes les méthodes de la
direction etc mais avait gelé nerfs
suffisamment solides pour supporter
pareille épreuve
serai je capable de me faire passer pour
folle auprès des médecins d'évoluer une
semaine entière au milieu des balades
mentale sans que les autorités ne
découvre que je ne suis qu'une
moins-que-rien armé d'un calepin
oui j'avais foi en mes talents d'actrice
et mes pensées de taille à feindre la
démence d'un bout à l'autre de mon
séjour
pourrais-je passé sept jours à l'asile
d'aliénés de blackwell island j'en étais
convaincu et j'ai tenu parole
elle s'installe alors dans une pension
pour femmes et s'il fait passer pour
folle jusqu'à se faire interner dans cet
asile qui avaient déjà une sinistre
réputation
là elle simule si bien la folie que les
médecins décident de l'interné après un
examen médical qu'elle trouve dérisoire
durant son séjour plus elle essaye de
sortir de son personnage plus les
médecins la trouve gravement atteinte
elle reste dix jours dans l'hôpital
observe les mauvais traitements les
humiliations la nourriture infecte et
l'incompétence des médecins et des
infirmiers à part la torture qu'est ce
qui pourrait produire la folie plus
rapidement que ce traitement
voilà des femmes envoyées pour être
soigné je voudrais que les médecins
experts prennent une femme saine de
corps et d'esprit
la fasse taire et s'asseoir de 6 heures
du matin à huit heures du soir sur un
banc qui ne l'autorisent pas à parler ou
à bouger pendant tout ce temps qu'il ne
lui donne aucune lecture et aucune
nouvelle du monde qui lui donne de la
mauvaise nourriture et de mauvais
traitements et qu'il voit en combien
temps elle devient folle de moi ferait
d'elle lui n'est pas physique et morale
une telle situation est loin d'être
exceptionnelle dans les asiles de
l'époque en france un scandale éclate à
l'asile de clermont l'oise en 1880 après
l'assassinât d'un des malades par l'un
des soignants mais même si on parlait
beaucoup de rumeurs sur les hôpitaux
psychiatriques personnes étaient encore
aller voir ce qui s'y passait
directement à sa sortie elle publie son
reportage sous forme de feuilleton dans
le journal de pulitzer où elle est
engagée
le succès de ce reportage est énorme et
lui fait gagner en crédibilité
il amène un scandale sur l'hôpital de
blackwell qui subit une enquête et
d'obliger d'améliorer les conditions de
vie de ses patientes et de manière plus
générale le budget alloué aux hôpitaux
psychiatriques est augmentée face à
l'engouement du public
elle publie son histoire dans un nouveau
livre dix jours dans un asile ce type de
reportage devient très populaire c'est à
cette époque que l'image du reporter qui
fouillent et percer des secrets se
popularise c'est le début de la yale
look presse ou presse à sensation c'est
du journalisme total
cette méthode est aussi reprise par
albert londres qui publie chez les fous
en 1925
après un internement volontaire et puis
la saison 2 d'american horror story qui
montre le personnage fictif d'une
journaliste s'infiltrant dans la zi de
briarcliff s'inspire fortement de son
histoire
pour ce qui est de nelly le reportage
clandestin reste sa spécialité
elle se met dans la peau de domestique
d'ouvrières et en 1887 à l'intègre
l'entourage d'un trafiquant edouard
faible ce qui est traîné en justice
suite à son reportage mais pas condamné
nelly est une tonne ce qu'earl une
reporter cascadeuse et d'autres
journalistes suivent son exemple par
exemple en testant des médicaments ou en
intégrant des corps de métiers parfois
dangereux
revenons un peu en arrière pour la suite
de l'histoire en 1872 paraissait le tour
du monde en 80 jours de jules verne dans
lequel le personnage de phileas fogg
faisait le tour du monde en 80 jours
quand même bien fait en 1888 nelly blaye
aimé l'idée de battre ce record et son
rédacteur en chef est tout de suite
enthousiaste vous n'y arriverez jamais
vous êtes une femme vous aurez besoin
d'un protecteur et même si vous voyagez
seul il vous faudrait temps de bagages
que cela vous ralentir et en plus vous
parler uniquement l'anglais
rien ne sert d'en débattre seul un homme
pour relever ce défi qu'est un an plus
tard elle remet l'idée sur le tapis et
cette fois elle est soutenue par poules
et r ce défi est pile le type de
journalisme qui plaît aux gens et en
plus elle est une femme ce qui ajoute
une petite difficulté supplémentaire
parfait pour le business
le new york world ouvre même les paris
et offre un voyage à qui estimera au
mieux le temps nécessaire pour son
périple
son voyage est aussi l'occasion de
mettre en valeur des droits des femmes
philadelphia in coillot un titre à son
sujet en confiant à sa brillante petit
journaliste une mission aussi spécial
que dangereuse le new york points d'un
seul coup accomplie pour la gente
féminine ce qu en une décennie personne
n'avait
réalisés depuis toujours de nombreuses
femmes méritantes sont restés au bas de
l'échelle
sous prétexte qu'on ne les pensais pas
capable d'agir par elle-même ce voyage
la preuve que le sexe faible quand il
est doté d'un esprit sain et d'accords
sein est libérée des carcans habituels
peut rivaliser avec les hommes les plus
brillants le 14 novembre 1889 elle
embarque donc avec une seule robe dans
ses bagages à bord de l'auguste à
victoria d'où elle arrive à swanton six
jours plus tard elle prend le temps de
passer par amiens où elle rencontre je
lui ai dit très enthousiasmé par son
projet et lui dit si vous le faites en
79 jours je vous applaudis ray dès
demain mais elle n'a pas attendre
s'attarder elle prend le train pour
brindisi traverse suez et la mer rouge
arrive à singapour le 18 décembre
elle ponctue son voyage d'articles sur
les lieux qu'elle rencontre et après en
arrivant à hong kong qu'une autre
journaliste elisabeth brys landes a été
envoyé par le cosmopolitan magazine pour
tenter de la doubler elle continue alors
areva yokohama début janvier puis à san
francisco le 20 janvier
les quatre derniers jours pulitzer fait
affréter des trains spéciaux pour
accélérer son retour dans les gares où
elle passe des orchestres jours des
journalistes l'interview elle arrive
finalement à clamer est accueillie par
des tirs de canon à new york après 72
jours 6 heures et 11 minutes et environ
quarante mille kilomètres parcourus
jules verne déclare alors jamais douté
du succès de nelly blaya son intrépidité
le laissait prévoir
hourra pour elle et pour la direction du
world our à hourra elle devient la
première femme a effectué le tour du
monde sans être accompagnées d'un homme
la précédente jeune bach elle avait
effectué un siècle plus tôt mais pour
accompagner un homme et elle s'était
même travesti pour l'occasion j'en ai
déjà parlé dans un précédent gentes
dames badass donc si ça vous intéresse
allez loire à son retour elle écrit le
tour du monde en 72 jours mais surtout
un jeu de l'oie et publiée en son
honneur
et ça c'est de la consécration après ça
elle s'éloigne peu à peu du journalisme
même si la défense des conditions de vie
des ouvrières reste l'une de ses
principales préoccupations et en 1895
épouser un millionnaire patron d'une
fabrique de bidons de lait et de 42 ans
son aîné ok après la mort de son mari en
1904 elle reprend les rênes de
l'entreprise elle brevet de nouveaux
types de bidons de lait et engage
surtout des réformes en faveur des
conditions de vie de ses employés
meilleurs salaires
leurs conditions de travail centre de
loisirs et bibliothèques pour ouvriers
etc
mais elle se fait escroquer et doit
vendre la fabrique en 1914
elle part alors pour l'angleterre et
devient correspondante de guerre pour le
new york evening jambes elle y découvre
aussi le combat des suffragettes est de
retour à new york en 1918 elle continue
de publier sur des condition féminine le
monde ouvrier l'enfance et de défendre
le droit de vote des femmes
elle meurt à 57 ans le 27 janvier 1922
elle est alors décrite comme la
meilleure journaliste d'amérique et le
prix nelly blaya club rue porter est
décerné aux meilleurs travaux produits
par des jeunes journalistes en 2018
il a été décerné à jody cantor et mégane
tu aurais pour avoir lancé le mouvement
mis tout je veux pas m'avancer dans des
prédications de mauvaises historiens
mais je pense qu'elle en aurait été fier
[Musique]